so what do we do when we find the
inverse of a function and there's
restrictions on the domain like this one
right here we have f of x equals x
squared plus 2 but only where X is
greater than or equal to 0 well that's
what we're gonna talk about the first
thing I like to do is I like to graph
this and just kind of see what it looks
like we know it's a parabola x squared
the plus 2 is shifting it up 2 so
roughly speaking this graph should look
something like this where it's been
shifted up to now here they're saying X
is greater than or equal to 0 that means
that we're only interested in the part
that's to the right or equal to 0 so
we're really just looking at this branch
this right branch of the parabola and
why are they telling us that well
there's something called the horizontal
line test and the only way that the
inverse of a function will be a function
is if it passes that horizontal line
test so what you do is you draw these
horizontal lines like this and if it
crosses the graph at more than one point
that tells you that the inverse of that
function you know will not be a function
so that's why we're restricting because
if we just look at this right branch
here this right half of the graph see
it's only crossing a once so that means
that the inverse will be a function now
another way to look at this is when you
find the inverse of a function
graphically what this is it's a
reflection over this line y equals ax so
if we were to reflect this ok or fold it
over this line what this graph would
look like is a parabola on its side like
this now you can see this actually is
going to fail the vertical line test
remember the vertical line test so for
this input there's more than one output
that's not a function right but if we're
just using this branch right here this
right branch when we reflect it over
we're just going to be looking at this
part of the graph ok
the top part and this does pass the
vertical line test it's only crossing at
most once so that means for every input
there's only one output ok the next
thing I like to do is I like to look at
the domain here so the domain of the
original function is what X is greater
than zero and the range is y is greater
than or equal to two
but when you find the inverse of a
function because you're switching that X
and the y values the domain and the
range switch so for the inverse our
domain and range switch so now the range
which was y is greater than or equal to
2 to the domain is going to be X is
greater than or equal to 2 the range
okay it's going to be what the original
domain was so this is going to be Y is
greater than or equal to 0 so you can
see over here on a graph yep that makes
sense
X is greater than equal to 2 and the
range is y is greater than or equal to 0
so they're just switching so this is
important because we're gonna want to
state this domain here when we find the
inverse of this function so let's go
ahead and do that now f of X you can
replace that with Y that's like our
output and now what we're going to do is
wherever you see X you're going to put Y
and vice versa so we have x equals y
squared plus 2 we're going to solve for
the new Y here work from the outside in
and we're going to subtract 2 from both
sides so we get X minus 2 equals y
squared and we're going to take the
square root of both sides now remember
when you take the square root of both
sides you get two answers right we're
actually going to get y equals plus or
minus the square root of x minus 2 now
let's look at this for a moment see
positive square root of x minus 2 is
this graph right here negative times the
square root of x minus 2 that nega is
going to reflect it that's this branch
of the graph right here we're only
interested in the positive 1 in this
case because of the domain restrictions
we want the range to be y is greater
than or equal to 0 and we want the
domain to be X is greater than or equal
to 2 and that makes sense as well
because you know if X is not equal to 2
or greater then you're going to be
taking the square root of a negative
number which is undefined so let's just
go ahead and write on here X is greater
than or equal to 2 we just want the
positive 1 here and this is going to be
your inverse function instead of Y we
can replace this with the inverse
notation F inverse of X to be a little
bit more precise about it now you might
be saying Mario what happens if they
said X is less than or equal to zero
like this part of the graph well then we
would want this part here we would use
the negative square root
- - if you want more practice with
inverse functions follow me over to that
video right there I call it my complete
guide to inverse functions and I go into
a little bit more depth so if you want
more practice follow me over that video
and we'll dive into some more examples